it's easy to spot fake news it's kind of
easy to spot when you see it because a
lot of it is very like clickbait dish
there's the kind of fake news it's like
a blown-up picture of Owen Wilson it's
like you won't believe how much weight
this actor is lost we quizzed people on
Venice Beach to see if they really could
pick out fake news headlines like this
one breaking news
Hillary Clinton killed during FBI raid
Trump Tower opens in Pyongyang the
capital of North Korea
yeah that's vague news everyone we spoke
to spotted those bogus headlines easily
but what about this one from the
progressive news site salon.com
Donald Trump threatens to deport NFL
players who defy him and that's just the
beginning he probably would say
something super crazy and dumb like that
a lot of stuff has my having it with the
NFL lately and Trump so I mean he duh I
feel like he does have the power could
be true yeah that's like a fake news
headline he said something along the
lines of like did someone could like
extrapolate that from what is whatever
his tweet said but I don't think that's
technically true that's pretty much what
happened Trump said that players who
don't kneel for the national anthem
maybe shouldn't be in the country and
salon took the logical leap to infer
that the president wanted to deport
insufficiently respectful players but
what about misleading headlines that
come from mainstream sources like CNN
Trump asks Japan to build cars in the US
it already does
it's true yeah I did hear about that I
read about it he may have heard about it
on CNN which later corrected the
headline to reflect the fact that Trump
said he wanted Japan to build more cars
in America given that would you consider
that headline to be fake misleading it's
just a little bit misleading
yeah the way it's phrased makes it
sounds like he's so dumb as the media
environment continues to fracture it's
natural for consumers to gravitate to
sources they trust and ignore ones they
don't but even respectable news sources
often deliver factual information subtly
blended with commentary take this
Politico headline which states the fact
that the Fed raised rates paired with an
editorial comment that such a move
signals the strength of trumps economy
this news commentary Hybrid lets some of
our interviewees to believe the headline
came from a pro Trump source I would
feel like that would be more not a
mainstream news it's actually Politico
Politico yeah and then there's the
confounding fact that partisan sources
occasionally report factual information
such as this fairly straightforward
headline about the content of recently
revealed text messages sent by an FBI
agent high up in the Clinton email
server and Trump Russia investigations
Justice Department IG report says Peter
stroke had biased state of mind do you
think that that sounds like a legit
headline yeah that sounds legit websites
that on
that's from Breitbart do you consider
them legitimate oh it's awful I
definitely screwed up on that one so
what's the news consumer to do in this
confusing environment one proposed
solution is the regulation of fake news
Congress held a hearing on just this
matter in October of 2017 with senators
threatening the social media Giants to
step up or be regulated you have to be
the ones to do something about it
Oh or we will French politicians have
begun debating legislation that would
give judges the ability to block what
they deem to be fake news in the months
leading up to an election I think that
infringes a little bit I would be
surprised if judges and France can
review every news story possible I mean
that just sounds crazy but Americans
have proven much more skeptical with
polls showing a strong majority
disagreeing with government regulation
do you think the government should step
in and regulate it not because the
government is corrupt and every time
they touch something it just goes like
like completely wrong you could say the
government can play a role in it but
then that kind of breaks you know
freedom of speech do you guys think that
social media companies like Facebook or
Twitter should do something to stem the
spread of fake news or should they
control it or regulate in some way I
mean they should but the issue there is
bias Americans have been slightly more
open to the idea of tech companies
policing fake news which wouldn't
violate the First Amendment in general
do you trusts companies like Facebook to
be transparent and have accountability I
do yeah I do but there's a generational
divide on the question with younger
Americans being more skeptical of tech
giant's regulating speech do you trust
those companies to be transparent and
accountable and perhaps in that
generational divide lies an answer
younger Americans don't know anything
else
a fractured media environment is the
reality into which they were born don't
really watch the news they're not on in
the morning watching Fox like not nobody
watches TV anymore I don't go on
Facebook as much anymore like Facebook
is now getting so for like older people
much concern about fake news is
ultimately rooted in a fear of echo
chambers or filter bubbles that cut off
consumers from diverse viewpoints but
that's an overblown fear with recent
studies showing that most Americans are
in fact exposed to a diversity of
viewpoints the echo chamber panic may
ironically be largely the result of an
echo chamber of political journalists
telling each other it's a big problem
we're more opposed to censorship I think
because we're so used to the variety of
opinions on online media literacy and
critical thinking skills are the most
valuable weapons for combating fake news
and Generation Z just may be more
equipped to navigate the complicated
media landscape than our baby boomers
Gen Xers or even Millennials the baby
boomers don't understand it you know and
the Millennials kind of understand it
but they haven't they aren't used to it
in the same way we're more able to do
our own fact-checking and more willing
to whereas like my mom clicks on
something and it's like this is the only
article about this topic Wow I can't
believe I found this oh and Wilson
really got fat he really did
[Music]